hey everyone i welcome you all to this
session
in this session we will learn the
process of performing api testing
in jmeter we shall begin with learning
what an api is
then we shall see why we use j meter for
api testing
then towards the end we shall understand
the process of api testing from scratch
with the help of a hands-on demo but
before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and click that bell
icon
so that you can never miss an update
from simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
with
what an api is we often come across this
term while reading any technical blog or
magazine
an api or application programming
interface is a programming code
that enables data transmission between
one software product
and another it is an intermediary
software allowing two applications to
communicate with each other
to understand api even better let's take
an example
for example you're booking a flight for
that you will begin with searching
flights online
concerning your destination departure
return dates
and many more filters to make all these
choices you interact with the airline's
website and access their database
and see if there are any seats available
on those states
and what the costs might be while you're
doing all this from the time to begin to
the time you finish booking your tickets
you're doing that with the help of an
api to simplify it even more
it can be said that whenever we use an
application on our mobile phone
the application connects to the internet
and sends data to the server
the server then retrieves the data
interprets it performs necessary actions
and sends it back to our phone
the application then interprets the data
and presents the information we wanted
in a readable way this is what an api
is so that means each time we use an
application like facebook
send an instant image check weather on
our phone
or make some specific choices while
online shopping we use
an api now when we have a good idea
about what an api is
let's look at another major thing before
going on to the hands-on demo
that is why we use j meter for api
testing
apache g meter is an open source
software and it is used to simulate
loads of various scenarios and output
performance data
in several ways including csv and
xml files and graphs we know that
the apache geometer is 100 pure
java application so it is available on
every os that supports java 6
or later some of these specific reasons
what makes
jmeter a perfect fit for api testing are
jmeter enables fast api testing
it performs quick scope tests and
enables load
and stress testing then as we know it is
an open source tool and supports
load testing and stress testing it has a
lot of plugins and
extensions j meter can be used across
several platforms and can use various
programming languages
now we know about api basics and
why we use jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of api testing
in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
apache jmeter website and
download the file to know the entire
downloading process
and installing jmeter you can check our
jmeter download and installation video
in our jmeter playlist moving on
i have my jmeter installed i will go to
the apache jmeter folder
go into the bin folder and open the
batch file
this might take a while and then the
gmeter window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections
on the left side all the elements of the
test plan
are added and on the right side all the
configurations of that element
are added as we are on the test plan
element
we can see the configurations of the
scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test
will be stored all the requests
listeners and everything will be stored
here
so moving forward right click on the
first j meter here
and select the add option
then in this option select the threads
option
and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or
created or needed to run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be
taken after there is an error or you can
choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of
users you want then there is a ramp up
period in seconds option
that states the time gap between the
user hits third
there is a loop count where you can
choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test
to run in finite times there is also a
scheduler here to help you schedule the
time
for starting the test and the time for
ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser
and search for some sample rest api for
testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is
r e q r e s dot n
or request response dot n
we will create and run get post
put and delete rest api request in
jmeter in the demo here in this link
we have all get post put
delete apis so we shall choose the first
link here
list users
here we have the link request open this
link
in the new tab
then we have got the url for this api
copy this url and go to the jmeter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group
and go to add in the box that appears
select samplers you can see all types of
requests that jmeter can work on
we shall choose the http request here
you will have to give the address to
some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or ipbox
we have to give the server name or the
ip
so here we shall paste the get api
request
url in the protocol box
we shall put the https if in the url
the protocol would have been http then
we would have left this box empty
in the url we shall put the url link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here
and that anything after the url would be
put in the path
so we shall remove the path from the url
and put it in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get api we will have to
give parameters
we will add the name in the parameters
and give the name as page and value s2
in this http request drop down we can
see all the different types of http
requests that gmeter accepts
for now we shall leave it to be get
since we are using the get api
and also let's name this http request as
get api now when our http request is
ready
we shall perform the test on it to
determine
what the results of the test will be we
need to add some more test elements
we shall again right click on the thread
group
go to the listener options then in the
box we can check the different types of
reports that jmeter provides us
for now we shall select two of these
let's choose
view results tree and the view results
in the table
now save the test i will save the test
with the name api testing
and finally let's run it for running the
test
there are three simple ways first you
can simply click
the green button on the run second you
can go to this
run option and choose to run the test
and the third way is you can
right click on the first j meter and
choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test
let's go to the view results stream here
we can see the green status that shows
the test was successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again
the status is green since we had put the
number of threads
and loop to be one there is just one
entry in both the results
now let's try one more thing we shall go
to the thread group and change the
number of threads to be 10 and run the
test again
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table
and see the testing being performed and
same happens in the case of view results
in table
now in the view results tree we can
click on a request and see different
information
here we can see the sample start load
time latency error etc
same in the view results in table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format
you can also see the response data here
this is the same data
as it was there when we copied the url
from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get api request
let's add the second request that is the
post request
again add a http request by going to the
sampler
in the thread group then come back to
the browser window
and click on the post api option
then open the request url in the new
window
then go to this window copy the url and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this http request as
post
api then
let's paste the url in the server name
or ipbox
again let's put http in the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path
in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the post option
this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option
and we shall have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
here you can check some advanced
settings also in case you need them
for now since this is just a demo we
shall keep it really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again
let's see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running
a required number of times that is 20
times again
i can see information about different
requests that include different
parameters like latency errors etc
now let's move on to our third api
request that is the put request
go back to the browser and click on put
request
open the request in the new tab
copy the url and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
put api
then let's paste the url in the server
name
or ipbox again let's put http in the
protocol box
address the server or ip address box and
path in the path box
and in the http request drop down select
the
put option this time here also we shall
have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
make the thread count to be one and then
we shall save the test
and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one
here by clicking on the api request we
can check a lot of data like the
response
body and response headers and same in
the case of view results in the table
you can see the data in a tabular format
let's make the thread count to be 10 and
again
see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running
a required number of times
and here i can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last api request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
url and
come back to the jmeter window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
delete api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox
again let's put http in the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the delete option
this time here there is nothing to be
added in the parameters section
so let's go to the two listeners and
clear what all is there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time
we can see the test running n number of
times
we can see the information of any api
request by just
clicking on it so this is how we
create run and perform api testing on
different api requests
in jmeter and with this we have come to
an end of this session
i hope you guys found it informative and
helpful if you have any queries and
questions
do let us know in the comment section
below thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here